cyber attacks a plague on the business
community that just won't go away this
time it's British Airways boots and the
BBC who are having to explain why their
employees personal information was
compromised
they're not alone a slew of companies
across the world have been affected at
least eight of them in the UK
so far British Airways boots and the BBC
have confirmed the attack each one
employs thousands of people
the contagion began with a file transfer
software called move it which suffered
the breach moveit was used by zealous a
payroll provider through which hackers
gained access to a host of companies
contact details National Insurance
numbers and Bank details may have been
stolen in the breach
there are still a lot of unknowns cheap
among them the identity of the attackers
there's been some speculation that a
russian-speaking cyber crime group is
behind this and indeed there has been a
spike in activity of this kind since the
war in Ukraine started but as of yet
it's pure speculation nor do we know the
number of people who have been affected
the exact details they've had stolen and
the size of the remedial costs that
businesses now face a russian-speaking
cyber crime group called klopp has since
claimed responsibility for the attack it
told the Reuters news agency that it
would name and shame victims who refused
to pay a ransom what this exploit does
is expose once again the vulnerabilities
of some of these major corporations to
their outsourced software Services it is
the software that they're using from
third-party providers that has been
attacked and that of course opens up
vulnerabilities in a wide range of
different customers for those shared
services many businesses on to Great
Lengths to
strafences
world of business this serves as a
reminder
that they're only as strong as their
weakest link
gabri no one Sky News